how's it
going how you doing that's the great
we're going to keep playing some
NeverEnding night nightmare uh can yeah
there we go we woke up I woke up like
this yeah I woke up like
this
oh I just had to show the door my booty
that was all I had to do I knew it it's
always the solution to most things in
the today's society just look at nck
Minaj I hear
something don't trust it
though what is it cell three hello is
anybody
there I'm I feel like I'm making myself
very vulnerable for a jump scare here
hey chair how's life oh you don't talk
cuz you're a chair that's
racist block a security how did we end
up up here this is bull
crapper we were like sleeping in our bed
and everything was fine I've been
sleeping in my beard I've been trying to
now don't know the lyrics I shouldn't
sing
okay as long as Justin Bieber isn't here
we're fine don't worry about it you look
so scared already what is the matter you
never played a video
game my God go why have you forsaken me
where did that that guy guy go anyway
Jesus I keep forgetting this G us jump
scares when it they get me man they
don't understand me but they get me that
was deep I should have a
salad uh oh there a giant
Barrel I better show it my
booty no all right well [__] you too
then what is this place what the [__]
are they doing in there
hydrotherapy never heard of
that don't jump scare
me oh God oh
God oh I don't like this oh no I do not
like the
this oh God don't show the booty don't
show the booty okay there's there's some
blood here that might be just a leakage
in the chair for oil that broken wall
looks kind of like America's flag or
some
[__] just
saying we're back here oh hell no I'm
not going down there oh come
on oh God damn it all right Bros if we
die it's your
fault I'm sorry it's just no way how we
do
it
tiptoe tiptoe with my toes
must be feel cold on the
metal at least we have our pajama at
least you know we have to stay
optimistic we have to be
happy oh
God what is
that I don't like this I don't like this
at
all hello is anyone
here look at my boot look at my booty no
why does no one want to look at my booty
what is this game I'm kind of booty
hating spewing storage or Block B we
should probably go in the storage
first let's go in here maybe we can find
something useful like a lantern or a I
don't know some
drugs someone probably already took all
the
drugs
hello just want to get out of
here and then go home and get drunk with
tequila and cry myself to sleep like I
always do oh God he's have oh God he's
making out
what what the actual F was
that what is real and what is not I
don't
understand oh we're back here what do we
do what do we do when he comes just run
just run I'm looking in the
window you can't hurt me when I'm
looking in the
window God damn it I knew that was a
terrible idea my ads are always
horrible what do I do we need to find
some weapon let's go this way let's go
this way yes the storage the storage
should should have it right
what did I miss it's always so the Ric
capsules how about those no dog office
what the [__] is this place is Snoop Dog
involved God damn it I knew it this game
was too good to be
true okay we're just going to have to
okay we're just going to have to dodge
him somehow maybe do like a little booty
shake to make the air vibrate enough for
him to get exhausted or something I
don't [__] it
now
hey hey pretty
lady
hi all right oh God oh God oh
God well [__] what am I supposed to do
with
then I'm obviously missing a pule pass
that is not good yeah let's go this way
then I woke up like this staring blankly
ahead just making my way making my way
to the
crow oh he's
blind [__] is blind it's blind as a
duck look at it should have not oh [__]
is blind don't [__] with blind [__]
blind [__] [__] blind [__]
blind blind [__] blind [__] blind
don't [__] with blind [__] is it
unethical thing to do yes we did
it dubstep music
[__] I was actually destined to be the
next KRC but then I was like I don't
want that ugly haircut so I was like
[__] it so my record label just picked
or whoever next and that was skrc so
true story hi had how you doing let me
pick you up nope all right at least a
high five or
something such a selfish hand only
giving hand jobs to
himself what is
this we are really bound to go down
there aren't
we oh we're going deeper we must go
deeper bro how do you feel about
that that's very interesting you have a
sick twisted mind you know
very sick almost is sick at all this
blood in this game like God damn it all
right we're we're here hello there any
blind people want to know why did I say
5 minutes
ago it wasn't even that much all right
he's
blind don't move
Bruce don't move an
inch ah
DMO
stupid
[__] he tried to grab my oh Jesus oh
what the fudge cake is
happening [__] jump scares everywhere
man you want to look at my booty you
want to uhoh uhoh uhoh uhoh uhoh he saw
something I woke up like this don't
touch me because you're blind and [__]
that is very gross yeah yeah let's go in
the dining hall let's have some
meatballs want to have meatballs Swedish
meatballs is my favorite dish in the
world let's make some meatball let's
make some meatballs in the kitchen
girl where's my
meatballs I specifically ordered
meatballs God damn it ah here we are
let's find them don't think I don't see
your barrels just cuz it dark out in
here yeah will find the
meatballs and I will eat them they give
me power my Swedish power what what do
you think how do you think we're this
awesome in Sweden
seriously it's like a pop oh God oh God
don't
move why does everyone want to make out
with me it's not fair I curse this
beautiful face curse it I
say
where do we go from now oh okay that's
cool my mom always said make out with
strangers but I don't think this is what
she meant honestly I don't know what she
meant that's kind of a weird suggestion
for a mom to make but I don't
judge I don't
judge I'm not a big fan oh God I God
stop making out with me just cuz I'm
pretty ah why
all right bro we can do this now this is
our moment this is our Rebecca
Black no no that [__] ah oh I walked
under
glass
[__] okay um uh you remember what I said
5 seconds ago take that back and uh
think about what I said now there we go
watch out for the glass the glass up my
ass that doesn't sound very pleasant
does it
do you see any glass I don't see any
glass of
my I'd appreciate it
input what the [__] in the
FR this game is harder
than I don't
know trying to think of an appropriate
sexual inuendo that's how hard it
is I get it that was pretty clever good
job me high
five is that a baby singing in the
background do you hear
it I am not interested I don't want to
make up with you my mom said that it was
a good idea but I don't always listen to
my parents you don't always have to
listen to your parents you can do do
whatever you want you it's your life
listen to John Bunji John bie John Bovi
yeah he know that [__] what he was
talking about I think that was a song
that was really good I would give myself
a high five block a we already been in
block a [__] mate we already [__] in
Block eight mate oh we're going
deeper this is like Inception Inception
that's how deep this [__] is Inception
setion chion
chap Inception Inception I I'm trying to
make sense out of it but I can't really
do
it I really liked Inception first time I
watched it but second time I watched it
I thought it was pretty
bad for I think for most people it's
probably the
opposite oh
well s
a while someone was having finger
painting party and I'm never
invited never why do I never get
invited it's like hey guys you want a
finger paint and no they say and then
they go and do it without
me what kind of friendship is
that
showers is this AET that does not look
like showers what the [__] oh well there
you go it's fingerprint paint showers
way to rub it in guys way to rub it
in
okay we got this pachos we [__] got
this so far we have not died a single
time except those five times but what
that doesn't [__] all right [__] [__]
[__] [__] [__] [__] [__] [__] [__] [__]
[__] don't attack me don't attack me I'm
dancing I'm dancing I'm dancing I'm
dancing you can't attack me cuz I'm
dancing dancing I'm dancing works every
time remember that Bros if you're ever
in trouble Just Dance It Off dance it
off I wouldn't well that's this is outtz
what the [__] this is
horrible a [__] dance dance well
sometimes you just dance too good and
they Mis interpreted to dance I can't be
responsible for
that no I
can't I will not be responsible for in
oh [__] [__] [__] [__] [__]
[__] that guy really likes
me he either really likes me or he likes
to eat my throat it's one of those two
things I not sure if I quite figured it
out yet all right careful careful
careful careful careful careful do a
little dance dance It Off dance it out
girl dance it out to the left to the
left everything you own in a box to the
left in the closet I hide my shoes and
then I go outside and P on you huh
cuz you wasn't true talk
about you baby hurry please hurry up
before the taxi leaves standing in the
front yard saying how I'm such a fool
talk about how never ever find a man
like you got me to say You must not know
about
me me I can have another man in a minute
M here in a minute
baby you must know about
me can another in
minute minute baby
oh this is quite the rare
sight Beyonce oh God
no take it all back then we were doing
so well
all right well I know what to do I just
need to make sure I don't actually
move I like how his facial expression is
like I don't care
whatever
whatever cuz this is my in the United
States of
Whatever
kind of reminds me of Outlast a little
bit this [__] doesn't it
Broly do it
no you think I'm a liar no you would
never say something like that stop
it look how little I care it's
like oh there's a zombie in front of me
well I don't care all right it's my best
interest to look at it no I don't care
this is me not caring this is mine I'm
not caring
face I don't care there you go we did it
it's probably going to be more though I
suspect many more I suspect many more
hoes but life can't always be about
suspecting in h it has to be about
specting specker Speckles wait I had a
point but I lost it somewhere
okay oh God oh God oh God he's coming
they're
coming wait we're block block a again
[__] ass like a [__]
bone H we just going here then it's
locked I'm not a big fan of these guys I
don't think they're a big fan of me too
they are a big Everything is awesome
everything is cool when you're part of a
team Everything Is Awesome
well at least the walls are optimistic
in this game I'll have to be happy about
that when you live in a
dream Everything is
awesome everything
is
uhoh everything is cool when you're part
of a
team I I'm going to have to run for it
look there's glass
there yeah I'm just going to have to run
for
it God damn it what what's going on yeah
I've told you repeatedly to address me
as Dr Smith but you're my sister yes I'm
afraid you're
mistaken where am I you're in a lunatic
asylum and have been for quite some time
why am I here why do you think you're
here cuz
I'm I did you what oh session please see
yourself
out what a [__] have some
decency that would make sense out of the
giant ass
house
uh-oh um it wasn't
me they never listen do
they wow she really doesn't give a [__]
thank
you that's how she blinks
too it's like oh so
dumb wait we're back here my God why
have you forsaken me what if God was one
of
us justce Moon walking son of a bu gun
oh we made it
exit I'm nice
hello oh
[__] what is this what is this
[__] oh God don't fall off never mind he
did it what oh god you're a little be oh
he's wearing my favorite pajama
too wait and we have Mr R bunny with us
Mr rally no what's his name
Mr okay I'll call him
Rudolph where's the two fairy Rudolph
where's the to
fairy I don't understand
Rudolph he's so cute it's adorable a
freaking
adorable
God damn it he still had the bad stamina
even in a young
age really got to work on that [__] man
really got to we is he wearing a diaper
that's
adorable maybe this will explain all the
[__] dolls and [__] but I mean if we
have Rudolph then what's the problem
right Rudolph yeah that's right I like
your voice Rudolph thank you I'm part of
One
Direction sure thing Rudolf whatever you
say no listen listen
up anyway Down star night to the best
song ever we know every I don't remember
what was next but it doesn't matter okay
Rudolph I had enough of
you why are we going here
anyway ah God damn it it started at a
young age
people just kept making me balls without
my
consent why mom
why I my childhood was just the worst
this is the same room as before as well
we're kind of going back it feels
like what um what did
that ah finally you're awake what the
check out what I found follow me um I'd
rather just hang out with Rudolph no
that's okay let's follow him
PS okay God damn it what is this
nightmare who would follow a little
young girl in forest in the middle of
the night there's obviously W walsing so
long well it's they have to be my
stamina I feel bad if like the the guy
has like this bad health condition and
that's why the game is about that's why
he can't run fast and I'm like run
faster he's really [__] slow let's be
honest here all right we have two paths
to take the nor or the South they're
both in the East actually let's go down
ah did it come
on all right oh see see the eyes out
there that's Spooks That's What I Call
hardcore Spooks when there's oh no
there's a little ratty hello M little
ratty don't talk to him Rudolph now wait
I'm oh God that's
disgusting that is we're going north
this time
around oh now I don't see
him
oh oh that makes
[Music]
sense ow oh thanks for that
chap okay with that lovely image
implanted in our brain we are going to
end this episode here if you enjoyed
this video please go ahead and hit the
like button Bros I know you did I saw
you do it don't lie to me anyway hit
subcribe com bro today and I will see
you in the next one stay awesome bro bye